my boyfriend has stated dry-cleans jinkx
Oh jinkx monsoon
I he'll go to my shows but how was it
he's like it wasn't jinkx well speaking
of that this photo what did you get this
you posted this the whole seat but
you'll only need me all right
Trixie the grown-up to her yeah
do you feel like a grown-up hey I turned
30 just a few months ago and it hit me
all at once that I am and now officially
a grown-up
on one hand though you go from being
like the oldest 20 year old anybody
could meet to like I'm just like a young
30 you know which is kind of different
besides that this isn't really relatable
and that's part of the problem with
traveling with comedy is I've had such a
meteoric rise to fame and fortune that
it's time for you to really relate to
anybody anymore because I'm like you're
supposed to turn 30 and you're supposed
to be like am I supposed to have kids is
this my wife do I like my house but I'm
just like all my dreams came true and
I'm Richard Davis and in all rules so I
don't know you don't have the maybe same
mile markers that other well like in
real like real relationships you know
it'll be like live like people having a
baby you know and think that's our
milestone we're having a baby and then
like gate world it's like well we're
open now that's your baby your baby is
someone else's load
[Music]
actually it's kind of my fourth big tour
and it's like well I see you you get you
would think you get better every time
but instead it's always stressful yet it
just gets harder because you're like how
about I put in my autoharp and they're
like yeah we saw that how about I tap
dance oh yeah three years ago ages three
and up you tap dance then what else you
got
so what else you got whatever we're
bringing out this time well I hope you
like one show because I'm gonna start
myself on fire opening night and no I'm
doing a lot more so the new show is it's
sort of the marriage between adulthood
and childhood because if drag has taught
me anything adults just want to feel
like kids that's why I don't go to drag
shows we all know this not a woman
unless although it might be but I guess
I like a show where can we make the
audience feel like kids but also address
some of their adulthood beers you're
bringing out a full band for the first
time right show is is not fun
does that feel like a big step as a
musician yes Mary
because I grew up playing guitar in the
woods you know sitting in a tree
barefoot about burn burn I'm like that's
how I learned music so to travel with
the band now is really cool because I'm
really challenging myself to make the
music in the looks as much of the focus
as comedy has been but you can't show
people the same thing over and over
again but last year I was a drag queen
under a dress so this year drycleaner in
a dress you know well this year I guess
a drag queen in more dresses yeah I'm
doing so much not to like reveal too
much the opening number has five costume
changes five eight one song yes I'm
trying to build five reveals in one song
so I'm like why not I want people gag
a little figure one a little bigger
thing won't click a thing that you could
pull string on the back you don't know
me and kind of talk I guess I just like
to dress out would you ever do another
documentary are you kind of one and done
cuz it was that you really opened up a
lot of your life
it was bracing it's not my favorite
movie to watch I watched it with an
audience once wine drunk and that was
enough for me because you know I'm a
drag queen I want to put hairspray and
concealer on everything you know I don't
like people seeing me getting ready and
dragged me and secure about going on
stage I like people to think that it's
always fine well drag is all about the
illusion right total and the illusion is
a little shattered if you get to watch
yeah that side of things
well RuPaul says that people love drag
because we represent the super-ego we
represent the most beautiful tallest
thinnest confident talented version of
ourselves and that's why people love pop
stars and stuff because that's what we
see in then and so in this documentary
you see the you see the Elmer Fudd that
lives inside the Jessica Rabbit I'm not
bad I'm just drawn that way
in the documentary there's a large chunk
all about fan interaction and people put
some heavy stuff on you oh my god it go
home with a suitcase of letters that
people said no we're gonna kill
themselves how do you process that well
and take the piece of paper put it right
through a shredder well I've learned
that like so I think of people how I
like idolize people like Amanda Lepore
will never know what she needs to me and
that's fine
[Applause]
I'll never understand what this means to
them but I know what trixie means to me
then you know even for me this has been
like the the way I've put clothes on my
back and travelled the world and how a
ledger you've come true and it's the way
of like you know reconcile with a lot of
the darker things that happen to me yeah
and continue to happen to me as you have
gotten bigger as a public persona and
more people know who you are and more
people are coming up to you and telling
you these deep dark things has it
changed at all how you interact with
people or are you still the same I keep
enough people in my life that are
absolute haters to balance out the love
okay I might wake up to a great tweet
from someone and then I literally went
on tour for ten days and I went to the
gym to see Jason Wimberly my trainer and
I walked into he goes you've gained
weight so like there is some balance
Ginetta sighs oh yeah he he once he told
me like he was like you know I charge
more for doubles I was like what do you
mean he patted me on the stomach and
went aren't you gonna introduce me to
your little friends with Katya who of
course will cut me down at any turn
right so I keep the haters my boyfriend
has David Drag Glee's jinkx Oh jinkx
monsoon I he'll go to my shows but like
how was it he's like wasn't jinkx well
speaking of that this photo what did you
get this you posted this oh I sure did
we just had our three year anniversary
this is my boyfriend this was as far as
I can remember our towel this was really
like the first public showing of this
relationship was and you notice I also
didn't tag them because I'm very
secretive right but um you know at three
years things you know things are pretty
serious and this is a long solution ship
I've ever been in and that's something
that informs grown-up because out like
an ages three and up and my show is some
of the comedy was about being broken up
with and then your moving parts a lot of
the comedy was about being single again
and it grown up this stuff is drawn from
three year relationship so it's like
it's a different world it's one thing to
fall in love with someone you're like
it's great I love them we've known each
other six weeks right it's another thing
three months in three years in three
three years in to try to keep it keep it
fresh and you you fall more in love as
you find new things you hate about each
other
total it's a thick it's a it's a rich
bra and my boyfriend hates when I put
him in my show hates it he's like you
know it's like you really have to tell
dick jokes about my dick in front of my
mom I'm like does she think we're gay so
we can share clothes right she's gonna
find out what does she think we're doing
but he's really wonderful and supportive
but again it's great for our
relationship that he's like you're cool
but jinx but that one's better
totally can you give me the CliffsNotes
on you and David like I want to know how
did that come together well when a woman
and a man love each other very much
we met on tinder three years ago but I'm
very private and so I've never posted
about on mine ever tagged him in
pictures I never when I bring in places
you know I I just like um I like having
a part of my life that's a little more
like this is over here and he's over
here and but I'm not like ashamed of it
or anything but in drag world it'll be
like this is my boyfriend I love him he
works as my assistant two minutes later
where's your boyfriend
Oh Kim right over here so like I also um
private for the reasons of like if we
ever broke up what I really want people
to message me like I'm sorry you're
going through a hard time
you know but after three years I'm like
we can we can post about it I have a
thing for um beautiful hairy Jewish men
and what you know is he the one he could
be the one
he's someone he's someone he's a one yes
I'm a serial monogamy person so this is
like my fourth long relationship and
which were gay people I think is a lot
yeah
because gay people a year is like people
are ready to buy you his and hers asses
towels you know gay people are you guys
gonna elope to Palm Springs but thirty
years to me is blown by but there's
definitely a lot of hiccups which you'll
hear about and grown up because there's
there's a lot of things you learn about
yourself you start to three years in a
relationship you start to go like oh
it's me the bottom is me and it's always
gonna be me you know right I'm a monster
I'm five
most six years into a relationship and
it's like oh maybe I am there sometimes
hello like I want somebody who looks
into the hood it looks into the bed sees
the monster and goes like yeah every
night light right we still live sex
three all the time three years in which
I think is good that's a good sign I
don't think straight people do that
mm-hmm I think by that point they're on
you know they have secret Facebook
account and cheating and all that and
maybe children yeah well I think part of
what I missed about my growing up
growing up experiences I couldn't go to
my high school reunion because I was all
stars oh-ho and so I missed my ten-year
high school reunion so I was ready to go
look at the hottest girls in the hottest
guards to my school and the losers and
everything and see what was up and I
kind of missed out but I like to imagine
that like I would have like helicoptered
in like sandy Frink and Romeo Michelle
you would've been sandy and not Romeo
Michelle in this scenario rich right oh
that's fair yeah I would have been Romy
and Michele and sandy and I would have
been like you know hey you called you
used to call me day in high school turns
out you're right
second of all I monetized it thank you
so much but I would have sent some of
those guys that would have definitely
been like I love you my boyfriend but if
I get a chance to it's over [ __ ] it's
over was it a conscious decision to not
put your relationship in the movie yeah
we just wanted to not make it really
focused on that I mean I we don't really
talk about it but my boyfriend's a film
producer and he produced his film okay
so he's the brains and the money behind
the operation is being in a relationship
as that helped kind of establish
boundaries in all places of your life
but you have this thing that like that's
just for me yes I like having that
boundary also I am so deeply
over-the-top committed to my work that
it has helped me reality checked that
like you can't work all the time you
know if it's up to me I'd be in drag
every day working all day every day and
having a relationship and having the
responsibility to someone else to be
present and like take the wig off and
put in a closet for a few hours it's
like I think really good for me good
balance
yeah and I don't strangers let's be
honest half the reason have a boyfriend
is so you don't have to it's like being
able to cook instead of having to post
mates everything let's get into Katia
doc sorry lost a nail oh I thought you
were getting up to leave you're like I
don't want to talk about if I just walk
down it's like you've mentioned a few
times what what change right now well
the evidence of what it's like to be a
drag queen if I was a normal celebrity
thirteen people would have flown in to
hot glue this nail back on my hand but
since I'm a man in a wig I had to call
her on the ground like Velma from Scooby
Doo
there we go tanka all good the
documentary it's very raw and really
gives an inside look to what happened
between you Katya with the Trixie and
Katya show nobody's gonna want to see me
without her today is probably the last
day of filming I would say ever has
Katya seen the documentary yeah when we
showed it to Katya our whole goal was
like let's just all agree that it's
gonna be shown exactly as it happened
and me and her and management and our
assistant from tour we all watched it we
were like that's how it happens and also
now because we're completely reconciled
and it's so long ago I think it's
important that people can see that like
a friendship like that can have a rocky
patch and bounce back you know by the
end of the movie time 40 minutes later
were friendly of you know she's gone
through treatment but I think that
because gay people have tendencies to
have issues with mental health and
depression and substance abuse not
telling stories like that will be part
of the problem but now you're back
together you're working together again
what is the future of that creative
partnership look like I remember when we
when she kind of was feeling more
herself again and we got back in the
studio and we started season four of on
she we finished one episode and she
stepped out for a smoke break and it was
like I just it was like I was being
showered with sunlight I was just so
happy it like it's all better it's back
to what it was and it's like cuz that
chemistry that both of us that YouTube
series we're in season five of it is
what we live for
yeah it's both of our favorite thing to
do and so we're filming season five now
and unless the view stopped rolling in
we're not gonna stop I mean it's weird
to think we're in season five we're not
thinking about stopping but the
viewership only ever growing I mean some
of those have like four million views
now why would we stop making him Jeff
new teeth oh I have yeah I have been
ears okay are you living my dentist dr.
Sun in West Hollywood she's the best
she's really beautiful on older woman
and she saw me at the Hollywood Bowl and
playing with shakey graves this other
folk musician yeah and she was like I
saw you at the Hollywood ball I was so
proud you were so good anyway I saw you
on the screen and it's time for veneers
sounds like uh so I didn't even go for
veneers I went for cleaning and left
with veneers but um that's how you know
you're a star yes that's why I know I'm
doing okay financially she offers me
veneers $20,000 and like throw him in
the car sure impulse buy but I used to
have country teeth and now I have um
they were like what color do you want I
was like I want Wisconsin white so LA
Brown yeah I think we have to leave it
on that note with the game white but LA
Brown thank you for having
you